hello and welcome to helping you realize
the full potential of postgres sql with
google cloud
my name is kelly sturman and i'm a
director of product management in the
databases group
later in this presentation we'll hear
from phil and tim from wayfair on how
they're using postgres on google cloud
in this session we're going to discuss
why so many of our customers are
choosing postgres to build new
operational systems
and what we're doing to help address
some of their challenges the team from
wayfair will talk about their work with
postgres on google cloud
so let's get started and start by
discussing exactly what postgres is
and a brief overview of its history
postgres is a modern open source
relational database originally developed
at uc berkeley
and its first release was in 1996
while commonly used to manage relational
data it supports a more comprehensive
set of data models
like json
key value
xml geospatial
and many more capabilities
through its powerful extension model
this rich data model support means that
postgres is used in a wide range of
database use cases
databases created with postgres are used
in every conceivable type of application
from the very simplest single user
database
app
to demanding enterprise applications
supporting tens of thousands of users
running thousands of transactions a
second
it's found on the simplest single board
computers to the largest linux servers
with hundreds of cores and terabytes of
memory managing petabytes of data
so why have so many of our customers
adopted postgres as a database of choice
well organizations have started looking
for alternatives to the commercial
database they have historically used
they've done this as a means of reducing
the perceived punitive cost and the
aggressive sales practices that have
somewhat soured their experiences
but given the number of open source
databases that are available
why should you consider postgres
well postgres has a number of attributes
that make that decision simpler
it provides a similar and in some cases
better set of functionality than the
expensive closed source alternatives
if you're looking for a database that
supports parallel query partition tables
stored logic replication
change data capture
rich data models and so on
all in a single product then look no
further than postgres
on top of this impressive functionality
postgres has demonstrated itself in
demanding customer environments time and
time again giving others the confidence
to use it in their own applications
all this
and a friendly and engaging community
with a rich set of tools and utilities
has made postgres an easy choice for
many of our customers
but perhaps the most important aspect of
postgres
is its role as an open api
while sql is commonly considered the
language of data and is indeed
responsible for the ongoing success of
relational databases
each relational database has its own
implementation with functions and
operators that behave slightly
differently and more substantial
differences in programmatic apis
what postgres has the potential to
deliver
is a common sql layer that is consistent
regardless of the database engine that
underpins it
postgres certainly
its sql layer could lead to a
standardization of databases in the same
way
we've seen linux change the enterprise
operating system world
cloud sql for postgres is part of google
cloud's fully managed database portfolio
it provides fully managed reliable
database instances with features that
make databases easy to set up backup
restore
and provide high availability
it's the same version of postgres that
you can download from the community
website with the ability to choose
between the version of the database that
suits your requirements
google takes care of the heavy lifting
on your behalf
patching and securing your databases
with very little downtime
cloud sql aims to provide the best
postgres experience anywhere in the
cloud
so given the many options you have when
deciding on where to run your postgres
databases why should you choose google
cloud well google understands the
importance of the role that open source
plays in the enterprise and is committed
to provide the best experience for users
of postgres
we particularly understand the
importance that postgres will play as a
sql standard for databases in the future
we offer a one-of-a-kind platform to run
your postgres databases using the same
infrastructure that runs many of the
google applications you use daily you
get access to fast and scalable compute
and high performance low latency
networks with a global reach
google continues to invest in its own
dedicated global network ben backbone
and standing up data centers around the
world to ensure you have the fastest and
most secure access to your data
google continues to offer the best
experience for developers whether you're
building out your own
vm based applications or building them
on top of kubernetes
google cloud offers modern apis and
frameworks whether you plan to use
postgres
to build modern microservices or more
traditional monolithic applications
we understand developers and are
committed to making your teams as
productive as possible
we've created integrations and
management tools to simplify how you
make the most of your data and we
provide rich and open apis to protect
your application
investments we've been hard at work
adding important features to cloud sql
for postgres
recently we added support
for logical replication and i am
authentication making cloud sql easier
to integrate with your core enterprise
systems
cloud sql for postgres now supports
over 140 flags and 44 extensions
we have tuned the operating systems on
our cloud sql instances for database
workloads
uh google cloud was the first to support
postgres 13 in the cloud
and in just a moment we'll talk about
cloud sql insights and cost
recommendations via active assist
our database migration service makes
migration simple safe and secure
dms is serverless so there's nothing for
you to provision or manage
dms will do all that heavy lifting for
you
more than 85
of dms migrations are underway in less
than an hour
and a majority of these migrations are
coming from other clouds
observability is critical for managing
your database deployments recently we
launched sql insights giving you best in
class database observability using open
standards
sql insights helps your developer teams
to understand performance issues whether
you're building a monolithic app or
using microservices
and now we provide cost recommendations
through activeassist helping you
right-size your resources and optimize
your spend
potentially saving you thousands of
dollars a month
so thus far we've been talking about
cloud sql for postgres now i'd like to
spend a few minutes talking about cloud
spanner and some work we're doing with
postgres
cloud spanner is the relational database
that banks game studios retailers and
organizations and many other industries
trust with their most demanding
workloads
it's the same database that powers
google's most recognizable products
spanner offers global consistency and
five nines of availability at almost any
scale without painful sharding or
re-architecture as you grow
spanner's new lower cost of entry
now makes realizing these benefits even
easier you can start small and be
assured that spanner will scale to meet
your needs
even with spanner and all of google
cloud's unique benefits our customers
want options
spanner isn't the only managed database
service out there we want our customers
to feel confident that they'll be able
to move their data and applications
elsewhere without a disruptive rewrite
the postgres sql interface for cloud
spanner that we announced earlier today
will provide the scalability and
reliability of spanner that enterprises
trust
along with the familiarity and
portability of postgres that developers
love
we're making it so you can bring your
existing skills and tools around
postgres
to take advantage of the unique
capabilities spanner has to offer in
terms of availability and scalability
so to sum it up
postgres is becoming the relational
database of choice for the enterprise
for many good reasons
we believe google cloud offers the best
place to run your postgres databases
and we're seeing a trend to make
postgres sql
postgres sql layer
act as an open api for applications and
deployments
now
i'd like to hand things over to our
friends from wayfair tim and phil please
take it away
thanks kyle hello my name is tim quinney
and i lead the product team for database
platforms here at wayfair i'm joined by
phil porthoin who is our elite architect
and engineer for database platform
development
wayfair is a platform that is solely
focused on the category of home across
our six brands including our marquee
wayfarer.com and our specialty brands of
perigold all modern dawson main birch
lane as well as our wayfarer
professional business we have more than
31 million active customers shopping and
catalog for more than 20 million items
from a network of more than 16 000
global suppliers
hiring the systems to make this all
possible is a team of over 3 000
software engineers and data scientists
when considering the needs of our
engineering community the use cases we
support run the gamut from integrating
with suppliers to build our catalog to
marketing the products empowering the
customer facing shopping experience
online
all the way to managing the delivery of
orders through our global logistics and
operational systems to accomplish this
our database strategy is focused on
providing well-paid tasks for our users
to quickly provision and deploy database
solutions that meet their scale
resiliency and latency requirements all
while providing high tier support and
subject matter expertise
core to this strategy is postgres and
google suite of database products
whether it be single region reads of
rights for smaller applications running
on cloud sql or globally distributed
system running on google cloud spanner
we have found that google's suite of
database offerings enable us to drive
innovation to share more about why we're
excited about postgres in the google
offering i'll hand it over to my
colleague phil
thanks ted
for me as an enterprise architect for a
fairly large engineering organization of
a couple of thousands of engineers and
analysts
technology matters
postgres sql being an
open source and freely used product
is the type of technology that enables
large enterprises like wayfarer to have
control over their own ethics in the
data space
postgres sql is a proven technology
our developers can use it with any
architecture and software stack of their
choice without compromising velocity and
portability
there is a massive amount of learning
materials documentation open source
guides
and community support is available
around the clock which truly puts
developers first however as most of you
probably know considerations about
databases don't end with developers
managing provisioning orchestration
monitoring and maintenance of physical
or virtual infrastructure
is a massive component of operating data
stores
google cloud platform takes the
infrastructure management challenge out
of the equation completely allowing us
to focus effort and resources entirely
on product development
using open source solutions helps the
wayfarer to transform our business in
much more ways than one but there is one
benefit that's hard to overlook and that
benefit is cost
in modern fast-paced technological
environments time to market is critical
and postgres sql on google's cloud sql
allows us to minimize the effort of
preparing our products and applications
to serve production workloads while
significantly reducing the overall cost
of the solution
we've discovered that supporting similar
workloads on cloud sql postgresql is
anywhere from four to eight times
cheaper than a comparable commercial
database engine provisioned on compute
engine after accounting for licensing
costs and depending on the redundancy
and distribution level of the deployment
of course
on top of that difference with cloud sql
being a completely managed service there
are additional cost savings associated
with dramatic reduction in operating
costs compared to deploying on-premises
or in an unmanaged fashion
this makes postgres sql a perfect
cost-effective solution for the majority
of online relational data storage needs
and welfare
however for some distributed use cases
where consistent safe rides to the same
data set are happening from multiple
locations spanning countries and
sometimes continents a slightly
different solution is required that's
where google cloud spanner comes in a
truly distributed and truly consistent
solution for relational database
workloads that require distribute
distribution
we're able to provision distributed data
stores within minutes and with almost
zero operational effort required from us
thanks to google's true time distributed
clock spanner is capable of providing
the same consistency guarantees as
postgres sql
at a minimal added latency cost
switching from writing and storing data
in a single data center to persisting
same data points in a globally
distributed database and having the data
available locally for clients around the
world requires next to zero development
time
and with technologies like postgres sql
interface for spanner software product
journeys can start with a local
postgresql database and shift towards
spanner later in the life cycle
providing global availability in an
effortless fashion
back to tim
echoing what both phil and kelly shared
the value proposition of postgres is
highly resonant to us it's open source
and cost efficient it has tremendous
community support with low barriers of
adoption for our users google's
investment in database products
leveraging postgres from cloud sql to
the new postgres integration spanish
spanner becomes increasingly compelling
for us because these products are
offered as managed services and enable
portability to follow the lifecycle of
an application
i'm really excited about this concept of
portability an application can start
with a simple cloud sql instance
maybe it's a proof of concept on a
friday afternoon before the team knows
it it's a runtime critical system and
through configuration you can enable
scaled breeds if it grows to the
occasion needing global distribution it
can be migrated over to spanner without
the need of a significant
re-architecture this saves us from
over-provisioning infrastructure fund
from perpetual rewrites of applications
and from the significantly significant
overhead of managing a started database
environment for these reasons
teams
such as our supply chain catalog
engineering marketing technology are
already leveraging postgres on cloud sql
for some of their systems additionally
spinner's quickly gaining traction with
our home services and customs platform
teams recently adopting
as we look to the future we're excited
to see what kind of performance and
operational gains can be achieved as we
consider moving other systems to cloud
sql and cloud spanner one that comes to
mind that's particularly exciting for us
is our user profile service which is
currently on a sharded database
environment across many servers this is
a prime candidate for migration to
spanner and core to our customer
shopping experience
and now i'll hand it back to kelly
thanks phil and tim for that and thanks
to all of you for joining us today we
appreciate it hope you have a great day